newspapers very occupied with the the
libra leader aired Miliband yesterday
and his speech from the conference let's
go at two frightened at once yes you can
say good morning to head Miliband I
think you're over the front page is all
the front pages and this morning and
before we get into detail could I just
ask you how do you do that how do you do
that standing there for an hour business
with without a note and yet you're so
forensic about what you're saying and
one thing leads to another there that's
some skill well I try to have a
conversation with people Aymond because
what I've suppose I've learned over the
years is that reading out a speech can
be quite boring for people and it's much
better to do it as a conversation I've
got some stuff written down in advance
obviously but then I just try and sort
of make it up a little bit on those
points its other things I want to say
and you know that that's what I tried to
do but I could easily ask you how you do
your job as well so look you got a few
plays a big part in what he to which
which was why that was a bit of
professional admiration at towards you
though the way you carry that out